the movie opens up with a brief
information about the first world war
where Serbia suffered a devastating loss
it is mentioned that more than
two-thirds of its male population
perished during the battle and the women
who survived were left to pick up the
pieces and start new lives as best they
could however this also meant that many
small towns were left with few or no men
at all the scene then shifts to a small
town named pokierp which is filled with
beautiful women there is only a single
male representative through the whole
town and that too he is very old one day
two sisters agnajanca and boginja are
seen playing around the pond next to the
cemetery Jenka is the responsible
sibling and she suggests that they head
home and avoid the cursed Pond due to
the legend that surrounds it however
boginja being the Carefree one walks
towards the pond without a care in the
world according to the legend their
great-grandmother Cried by the pond for
seven days and seven nights when her
husband did not return from the war her
tears made pond so salty that even sea
animals started Living in it after a
week of mourning she swore to toughen
her heart like a stone and became the
best Whaler on the mountain Whalers are
women hired to cry at funerals a
tradition that has been passed down
through generations in this family which
the sisters are also a part of in poker
if a boy is as tall as a rifle he is
considered Ready for War however with so
few men left in the village and with the
meager number of deaths nowadays the
family business is slowly becoming
worthless following this we are informed
that only two men have ever returned to
pokerp from the war but sadly both died
soon after the first was crushed by a
gravestone and it is unclear whether his
death was accidental or due to his
wife's anger over his infidelity rest in
peace and the second man who knew that
he could not defend the village of women
by himself set up a Minefield in the
vineyard however he did not Mark the
positions of the Mayans and died after
stepping on one of them the vineyard is
the main source of income for the
villagers but after the second man left
a dangerous Minefield beneath the women
who remained have renamed it as mine
yard since then the group of women draw
straws to see who will be the next
person to pick the grapes sadly most of
the time they are unsuccessful as the
minds explode and blow them up to
Smithereens I cannot tell if this is a
comedy or a drama one morning the
sisters are approached by NADA a young
girl who wants to hire their crying
services in advance since she has drawn
the Short Straw and is going to the mine
yard next however as she has to pay in
advance she asks the sisters to give her
a demonstration of their wailing
performance the two immediately agree
and start their sample performance
however Jenka has trouble wailing
because her customer is still alive she
tries to think of sad things to make
herself cry but nothing seems to work in
one of her memories she recalls the day
her friend Sanjaya got married but was
immediately separated from her husband
and left mute by the war to help her her
sister boginja reminds her that she's
turning 22 soon but has yet to find love
and with the lack of men in this Village
it's unlikely she ever will luckily this
unusual thought brings both sisters to
tears it won't bring me to tears though
it will
meanwhile Nader reveals that she kissed
a man once an old man named Grandpa bisa
the only remaining male in the village
while the sisters are disgusted by this
Neda explains that she'd rather
experience her first time with an old
man than never at all however grandpa
bisa is growing increasingly ill and the
famous Village witch also cannot do much
to help in the evening NADA and the
sisters venture to the local bar where
the women of the village gather to
indulge in drinks and attempt to forget
their Soros in the bar a famous band
named ratija's band plays melancholic
funeral Tunes which do little to left
anyone's Spirits however NADA has made
up her mind to make the most of her
remaining time and implores the
bartender to serve the potent spider
Brandy instead of the usual cheap drinks
as a result Every Woman starts having
Vivid hallucinations of the deceased men
who have left a void in their lives the
following day before going into the
Minefield NADA tells the sisters that
she has arranged for them to have some
fun with Grandpa bisa moments later she
enters the Minefield steps on one and
dies in the blast next the Curious
sisters visit bisa's Hut but neither of
them is willing to go in first in an
attempt to begin the process baginja
pushes Jenka onto the bed with the old
man unfortunately when bisa appears
close to her face it causes her to freak
out and scream unintentionally giving
him a fatal heart attack his heart does
not beat again and he dies on the spot
not a bad way to go all things
considered as a result of their actions
the sisters are condemned to be burned
at the stake they are tied together and
placed near a fire baginja desperate to
avoid death proposes a condition and
Promises to bring back a better man than
bisa within three days The Village witch
agrees but she makes sure to curse the
sisters saying that if they fail to do
so their great-grandmother's soul will
rot in a place worse than hell that's
right we talking about Burger King in
the next scene the sisters embark on a
challenging quest to find a man but
their search proves to be much harder
than they expected on their way the
first man they encounter belongs to to a
female only town where the women
fiercely guard him and scare the sisters
away the second man turns out to be a
woman disguised as a man attempting to
join the Army to help with repopulation
finally they arrive at the city and are
surprised to see the men from their
hallucinations there janca finds herself
smitten with dragaljube a daring circus
performer known as the man of steel who
Wows audiences with his Canon launches
as soon as their eyes meet they feel a
spark of Attraction and Drago offers to
take Jenka on a flying Adventure a stunt
he usually reserves for paying customers
in the meantime baginja is drawn to arsa
a Charming singer who captivates the
hearts of all the girls in the city with
his smooth voice as Jenka and Drago soar
through the air their bond grows
stronger but their flight ends in a
plunge into a nearby lake Drago
struggles to stay afloat but Janka
rescues him and revives him with
mouth-to-mouth resuscitation impressed
by her courage and quick thinking Drago
offers her a position as his assistant
meanwhile after being surrounded by a
group of women arsa makes a bold
declaration he announces that whoever
catches the red rose thrown into the
pool will be his Queen and so the women
frantically fight to grab the flower
with baginja managing to emerge
Victorious as everyone is distracted by
the commotion Drago makes his Escape in
a car along with Jenka he also summons
arsa to join him implying that they know
each other soon baginja also gets into
the car and they set off on their new
Journey as the four of them travel
together it becomes apparent that Jenka
and Drago have a strong connection while
ASA is not interested in boging's
advances the group makes a pit stop to
change out of their wet clothes and arsa
finally becomes attracted to bogenja
when he sees her in a semi-nude state
the next moment they start making out
and so the other couple gets into the
car and drives away on their way they
run into some trouble as jenka's hair
gets stuck in the door despite her
attempts to convince Drago to not go
back to Poker he is eager to see a town
full of women and experience the beauty
meanwhile boganj manages to convince
arsa to ditch Drago and escape to
Belgrade where they can find Fame
together however during their getaway
they accidentally steal a hearse with a
deceased body inside along the way to
pokeep Jenka manages to persuade Drago
to share some stories about Belgrade
including the upcoming Palace Albania a
towering structure that dreams are made
of Drago mentions that he hopes to
perform his circus act from the top of
the tower someday although Jenka
considers going to Belgrade again she
feels guilty for not keeping her promise
to her people so they stick to their
plan and head to pokirp where the women
draw straws to decide their chores for
the day and Sanja is the unfortunate one
however their work is disrupted by the
unexpected arrival of Jenka and Drago at
first the women mistake Drago for an
illusion but they soon realize that he's
real and they swarm around him with
excitement except for a tired Sanja
while Drago relishes in the attention
Janka cannot help but feel jealous later
they utilize Drago's circus skills to
safely collect Graves he peddles a
bicycle on ropes across the mine yard
while Janka is Tethered to him
effortlessly grabbing the fruit without
having to touch the ground as night
descends everyone Revels in making wine
the traditional way by stomping on the
grapes in a large bucket Drago happily
joins in the party while Sanja watches
him from a distance meanwhile the witch
keeps her promise and allows the soul of
the sister's great-grandmother to rest
in peace however Janka begins to feel
lonely and frustrated because everyone
else seems to have what they want except
her but her thoughts are interrupted by
the arrival of boginja who has come back
to help in the next scene as the sisters
head to the bar they find Drago having
fun with other women this infuriates
Janka and in a fit of jealousy she hits
him in the groin before declaring to
everyone that he belongs to her and that
they're leaving for Belgrade
unfortunately the women merely laugh at
her and continue with their celebrations
when nothing works Janka takes a daring
step by boldly kissing Drago she then
confesses her love for him and urges him
to leave with her however Sanja who has
been yearning for a kiss from ago ever
since her wedding day was ruined becomes
envious and also plants a kiss on him
disregarding his explanation that he can
only kiss Jenka after some time arsa
also arrives there and the women
immediately surround him this time its
boginja's turn to feel envious Ursa
quickly drinks some spider Brandy and
requests the band to play some music so
that he can dance with boginja on top of
the table but things turned violent when
ratija also desires to dance with arsa
leading to a scuffle between her and
boganja which leaves their feet bleeding
from the broken glass Drago grows weary
of the spectacle and flips the table
putting an end to it all after this a
bitter argument between the men and soos
and the women suggest that the best way
to determine who is the better man is
through their bedroom skills Drago
agrees but Jenka hurls a glass at his
head revealing her possessiveness and
envy the following day Drago wakes up to
find Sanja hovering over him trying to
get closer she confronts him about his
Macho behavior and reminds him that it's
okay to let go of his pride however deep
down she knows that Drago is committed
to another woman so after a bit of
consideration she kisses him one last
time and sends him off to be with his
true love next as the sisters leave for
Belgrade in their car Drago tries to
follow them however they angrily Ram him
with their vehicle for all the problems
he's caused as of late Ursa on the other
hand tries to escape from the women
waiting to spend time with him and
accidentally ends up in the dangerous
mine yard just when it appears as if he
is going to die the sisters arrive and
Bogan just steps up to rescue him from
the Minefield before she sets out she
bids her sister an emotional farewell
urging her to continue her way to
Belgrade and live a full life with a red
rose the same one ASA threw on the day
they first met pinned to her chest
boginja then moves towards her beloved
and they share a passionate kiss the
villagers watch in awe as the two lovers
dance in a beautiful and moving
choreographed display unaware of the
minds detonating all around them they
move in Perfect Harmony until the final
deadly mind blast takes them both
devastated janca gets into her car and
drives out of the village she remembers
that her sister had bathed in the cursed
Pond and believes that it was the cause
of her untimely demise however the sun
is shining brightly symbolizing a
hopeful future and she begins to imagine
the life that Draco had described to her
the movie ends on a hopeful note with
Jenka dancing to a lively Rhythm as she
Twirls and Spins she knows that she is
ready to start a new chapter in her life
leaving the past behind and embracing
the possibilities of the future
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching